this is the last major event for
literature humanities this semester a
part of course from your final exam I
welcome you this morning this is the
first time we have tried to stage a
global lecture in literature humanities
I am delighted that I was able to invite
to professor Carroll in the world of
Bard College a professor of classical
and historical studies there
Carolyn professor Dewald is also the
director of the first year program at
Bard College which is akin to literature
humanities here as you will know already
professor Dewald is an extremely
distinguished scholar with main interest
in ancient historiography she is the
translator of the edition of Herodotus
that we've been using in literature
humanities this semester
and so you will already know the
qualities of the introduction to that
volume the qualities of the translation
and the qualities of the notes so it is
a real pleasure to be able to welcome
Professor Dewalt here after being so
impressed by the Herodotus work itself
to be able to enjoy her company this
morning so please welcome her along with
me
thank you very much for having me as you
know by this point having read as many
texts as you have read hubris leads to
ought a and I have perhaps done
something here that's a little bit
hubristic I've never this is literally
true I've never given a speech that had
pictures in it and I now for the first
time I am talking to a very large
audience of people who know the texts
with about a hundred forty images and
I'm hoping Gareth and I talked a lot
about it as I agreed to do it it was a
fascinating idea to try to sum up a
people as variegated as deep as
complicated as the Greeks and I couldn't
do it there's no way that I can give you
a lecture that would sum up the Greeks
so what I thought given the fact that
I've recently learned the miracles of
art store I thought I would try to give
you a lecture that would cover things on
usually a pretty superficial level but
would try to tie together all the texts
that you've read bring them all in into
a sort of basic sociology of the Greek
world using the pictures both the
pictures of the vases and a couple of
statues and the ancient monuments of the
Greeks themselves and as importantly
pictures from the 16th through the 20th
century of artists who are responding to
the same texts you've read and are
putting their own interpretations on
them so I hope it'll work that the
pictures will kind of give an extra
dimension and extra depth if you will
allow us to be a little bit up close and
personal with the Greeks that you've
been reading about
and congratulations for reading these
texts I just I think for a classicist
it's it's unbelievably heartwarming to
see an audience this size of people who
now have these texts and just let me say
this is something I say to every class
of mine every decade or so take them out
again don't sell them for heaven's sakes
but take them out again and reread them
and you'll find your own relation to the
texts have changed you'll find when you
have your first child that a lot of
things will look different you'll find
when you start to lose your parents a
lot of things will look different but
these are texts that can stay with you
your whole lives and congratulations for
having read them okay the works you've
read this semester have been saved for
2400 years and more because for much of
that time they've been used to shape the
values the political and personal
attitudes of the educated classes of
Europe and the Americas they were saved
initially primarily a school text for
the educated upper-class males who ran
things what I'm doing now is not a talk
and argument with an elegant thesis but
rather an encounter a Catina a mixture
of some glimpses through text and image
of a remarkable people whose voices you
have encountered this semester it is
their weird combination of familiarity
intimacy and complete hoary ancient
foreignness this is a Gorgon that I want
to contemplate with you today using
their words but also the art their own
and that of later ages about them a
classic example of what I mean about
familiarity and strangeness comes in the
scene in Iliad 24 when Priam kisses the
hand of Achilles the enemy who has just
laying his son and here's a painting
from about 590 or know this is a
painting from the Burgos painter of 490
you can see Priam coming in as Achilles
is reclining and oddly enough Hector is
lying dead under Achilles couch we don't
think that really happened but that's
what the painter imagined
it is a touching scene the old man and
the young man weep together in pity for
each other since they are both facing
death the deaths of their recently
deceased loved ones and soon their own
deaths too but just last year I focused
really for the first time on the fact
that when Priam overcome by the sight of
his son's dead body a sleeve to hurry
home
Achilles turns and snarls a threat at
him no longer stir me up old sir you
must not further make my spirit move in
my sorrows for fear I might not let you
alone in my shelter suppliant as you are
and I might be guilty before the gods
orders in other words Achilles threatens
to brutalize if not kill the broken old
king homer adds he spoke and the old man
was frightened and did as he told him
now a lot of what we'll do in this talk
is about the tension between the warrior
citizen who is armed is ready to fight
has fought in wars and then is
unbelievably skilled at words he has to
be a doer of Deeds and a speaker of
words in order to control and mitigate
the effects of the aggressiveness of his
warrior culture and I wanted to start
with this picture because I think it
shows that perfectly Achilles warns
Priam but he warns him that things could
turn very ugly very quickly here I make
no pretense of summing up the Greeks
instead I want to look with you at some
of the aspects of this culture that to
me convey the mixture of their profound
familiarity and also profound
strangeness that makes them so
compelling to us I've divided my remarks
here into three sections all of them
things your mother said you didn't talk
about in public politics sex and gender
and religion perhaps it's the wide
variety of images ancient and modern
created in a variety of mediums that
will most eloquently testify to the
continuing relevance of the works that
you to now have possessed for yourselves
and what Thucydides calls a container si
a
a possession for all times okay first
politics ancient Greek male warrior
bands were the basis in beginning of
friendship this is a ninth century vase
that already shows something like a
hoplite line of warriors although it's
contested when the hoplite line actually
came in the indo-european warrior band
created basic social bonds bonds of
friendship and family it also led to the
emphasis on competitive individualism
that distinguished the Greek world of
our texts from other great early
cultures in which one was the subject of
a king and here's de Reyes as you know
even in his palace at Persepolis he's
the king that thought about first
warring against the Greeks but he died
and his son Xerxes actually take up the
job I also wanted to show you this is a
ceremonial staircase at Persepolis at
the huge Palace complex of Persepolis
that de rious had built where all the
people from all the different subject
states could bring their gifts to the
Persian king and if you saw these people
going up the stairs there each of them
is a very highly individualized
different subject people bringing its
distinctive tax to the king from the
early 7th century and perhaps much early
much earlier Greek warriors were the
heavy armed bullies of the ancient world
they were in the classical and
Hellenistic period even hired as hit men
by wealthy foreign potentates Xenophon a
pupil of Socrates as a classic text here
Persians dressed in skins and using bows
from horseback and this is a Greek poet
probably right after the Persian Wars
here's another one
they really enjoyed showing themselves
beating up on the Persians but we also
have a remarkable gold leaf itching done
that was found at the Oxus Treasury in
Tajikistan recently that probably is as
good at a indigenous
description of Ana Timon ed warrior Ana
common and persian warrior this is what
he would have looked like to his own
people
so Persians dressed in skin and used
bows from horseback Greek foot soldiers
carried a panoply and panoply is a
modern word that actually comes from pan
everything and hopeless
armor so panoply is the whole shebang
all of your armor including breastplate
Greaves on the legs a helmet shield
spear and sword arms that all together
wait at least 70 pounds clans fought in
hoplite formation every Greek young man
at about 16 was inducted into his
father's fighting unit and from 16
through 25 or even 30 was expected if
his family could afford it to spend a
great deal of his time training and
fighting in his clan unit the
consequences for the texts you've been
reading were various one that may look
frivolous but was not is that training
for military duty led to serious
exercise for young Greek boys in the
gymnasium but also in what we might call
line dancing the choruses of the dramas
that were one of the glories of 5th
century Athens were made up of citizen
males who had been training since
childhood to move in line with other men
not breaking rank and managing the
panoply of their armor besides the
workouts in the gymnasium and the
emphasis on the beauty of the fit male
body
we're not merely expressions of
aesthetics but rather part and parcel of
the need to have an experienced and
ready hoplite fighting force more
importantly for our understanding of
politics hoplite warfare placed a strong
value from the beginning on morale and
especially group cohesiveness here's a
modern rendition of the Battle of
Plataea and I selected it because you
can see how the hoplite formation works
that each man protects both his left
side and the right side of the man next
to
the hoplite line that guaranteed the
success of the battles described in
Herodotus and Thucydides required a
trust in the man to the left and right
of you and this required also a basic
sense of fairness and friendship
prevailing in the fighting unit it began
with a friendship of individual warriors
in the Iliad the classic friendship was
that of Achilles and Patroclus and here
Achilles is binding up a wound that
Patroclus suffered this was later from
at least the sixth century assumed to be
a homoerotic bond and that's something
we'll mention again when we get to sex
and gender the needs for bonds of trust
and equality between warriors also led
pretty directly to the later political
development of Issei gorya freedom of
speech and I saw no Meah equality under
the law the fighting line the hoplite
unit with each man's shield protecting
both himself and the man to the left of
him was based on the voluntary heroism
of the individual citizen warrior both
Sparta and Athens in the Classical
period produced powerful armies because
in different ways their armies were
based on the commitment of the citizen
warrior to holding the line for his
friends and comrades the tensions that
resulted from this fact are encoded
already in the first work you read in
this class The Iliad the so called Greek
Bible begins with a contest between the
man with inherited status
here's Agamemnon and you can see what a
creepy is already in this picture from
1810 it's a German painting from 1810
and you can see Athena actually in the
text as you know he doesn't have a
helmet on clearly your your painter
thought it would be nice to have a nice
helmet but what she does is sees him by
his hair hold him back by his hair and
keep him from slaughtering his commander
so the Iliad begins with a contest
between the man with inherited status
and the man with natural ability so to
speak the classic tension that can't
exist between the old fart and the young
turk in any organized
between them Achilles and Agamemnon
almost destroy the cause they're
fighting for and many of their comrades
died we're getting back to the tension I
talked about right at the beginning of
the warrior has to be a doer of Deeds
but he also has to be a very careful
speaker of words so that the natural
tendency to have recourse to your arms
isn't going to happen
Achilles has been told by his divine
mother that if he stays in Troy he will
die there and in book nine he struggles
with whether it is worth his life to
fight for a man who has dishonored him
and has thus taken away his reason for
being there at all this is a painting by
Angra the famous french painter about
the same time as the German one you just
saw
1800 so already in the 8th century the
quintessential Greek epic articulated
the question every individual warrior in
the later polis also had to ask is it
worth putting your individual life on
the line for the collectivity the answer
given in the poem is if you do not your
dearest comrades will die and this is an
English painter Gavin Hamilton 1760 the
death of Patroclus and Achilles mourning
him death and battle was always possible
for the Greek citizen warrior and this
gave an intensity to both death and to
life and the warrior death was honored
and here some of you may have seen this
before the Met had to send it back last
year this is a euphonious face of the
death of tsar pedan the son of zeus and
you can see Hermes there waiting to take
the body back to his home in Lycia from
the Homeric Warrior we move in a
straight line to soul on the Archon of
Athens in 594 BCE the architect of a
political structure that encodes the
earlier archaic Warriors values as the
foundation of a democratic political
system that holds ISA no Meah
equality under the law and ISA goryeo
freedom of speech at its core
or you encountered Solon in Herodotus's
first book he has told the Athenians
here he's arguing with the Athenians
that he that they must follow his laws
for ten years while he goes on a long
trip and that of course as Herodotus
says is because he didn't want them to
force him to change the laws so he just
takes off for ten years on his 10-year
journey he encounters Croesus the
amiable but clueless king of lydia here
you can see Croesus having a good time
at his table who did not Croesus did not
understand that no man can be called
happy until he has died and the rest of
us know the end of his story
Croesus thought that his vast wealth
made him happy and he turned out to be
very very wrong this is Croesus on the
funeral pyre that's being set and we
know from Herodotus at least Herodotus's
version is that he was taken down from
the pyre but he had to spend the rest of
his life as a captive as a servant of
the king of persia in greek terms tell
us of Athens the man Solon calls the
happiest of all really did have it all
both kinds of good death available to a
citizen tellus lived out a full span of
years with enough money in health and he
saw his grandchildren grow up healthy
that would have been an extraordinary
thing in a age of high mortality of
children by dying in battle however he
also gained the honor of a young hero's
death and here we go back to a ninth
century pot that shows again the
honouring of the hero at death that was
something basic the hero who falls in
battle is the one who is honored most in
his death by dying in battle tell us
also gain the honor of a young hero's
death falling at the end in victorious
battle for his city and receiving public
honors at his tomb and here's Alec
oh--this or one of the vases that in the
5th century were put in the tombs of
fallen warriors and this is probably a
picture of the young man who had died
Herodotus's histories are full of the
Greek determination never to lose the
precious freedom their courage in battle
has won for their cities as two young
Spartans tell the wealthy Persians say
trap hide our knees you've never
experienced freedom and you have no idea
whether it's a pleasant state or not if
you had experienced it
you'd be advising us to wield not Spears
but even battle axes in its defense in
Herodotus's eyes although the
intelligent deployment of Persian
resources could easily have triumphed
over Greek resistance the determination
of Greek citizen troops united for once
in an uneasy Confederacy was just barely
good enough to stave off circus invasion
here Xerxes from pur cyclist and the
imposition of autocracy on the Greek
world an eloquent articulation of this
basic theme the evolution of warrior
values into the values of the free and
democratic state comes of course in
Pericles funeral oration in Thucydides
second book they are Pericles praises
the Athenian citizen warrior who has
made his city famous throughout the
known world but at home is tolerant of
his fellow citizens he will sacrifice
his life for the sake of the civilized
and democratic freedom that the city
offers him and his fellow citizens
here's a kind of odd picture again by a
German 1852 of a enthusiastic audience
listening to Pericles holding forth this
Colossus or Ostia produced about halfway
between the Persian Wars of Herodotus
and the Peloponnesian War of lucidity
in 458 perhaps delivers the fullest
articulation of this set of Athenian
democratic values it tells of the blood
curse that dogged the house of Atreus
and here's a German performance from
about 1980 in which Clytemnestra in
modern dress has just killed her husband
and his lover here is an ancient pot
showing young arrestees coming back and
getting a justice with his mother
looking somewhat distress
in the background here's arrestees I
have this on my door at my office
here's arrestees being pursued by the
Furies and Apollo speaking from his
shrine at Delphi tells Orestes purifies
Orestes and tells him that he has to go
to Athens here's a copy of the famous
Vidya statue of Athena
here's her home in the Parthenon the
final solution to the problem of massive
transgenerational blood feud and curse
is resolved by Athena's decision to
establish a jury trial on the Areopagus
the hill of Ares in Athens and I got
this actually as a Flickr picture
I hope this young man doesn't mind but
this is the Areopagus and of course the
reason it there's so many pictures on
Flickr is that the Areopagus was also
the hill on which Saint Paul gave his
famous speech to the Athenians several
centuries later but this is where the
Council of Ares the council met that
gave in at least Aeschylus's version the
mythic rendition of the first jury trial
the arguments given by Apollo and the
Furies in humanities are a bit
ridiculous even Athena's own claim that
she'll vote for the male in all things
because my goodness she didn't have a
mother was I believe designed by
Aeschylus to look specious the truly
important thing that happens in the
third play is Athena's proclamation of a
structure a set of procedures that will
from that time forward allow citizens to
begin to trust in the fairness of their
city institutions and above all in the
rule of law as the way to resolve
differences and then a crucial second
part her ability to win the Furies
assent to these new institutions and
here is a great it's a French production
of the Oresteia and here's the Furies
beginning to listen to a thinner they're
still sort of skeptical but they're
thinking about being won over
as Herodotus tells us Aeschylus's
brother died in the Battle of Marathon
his hand chopped off as he lay hold of a
Persian prowl and Aeschylus himself
apparently chose as his only identifying
information to be placed on his tomb
when he died in 456 two years after the
Oresteia that he had himself being a
marathon all MCUs a marathon fighter and
this is the great tomb at marathon where
the Greek warriors who fell in that
remarkable battle are buried of the
seminal battles in 490 and 480 that
Herodotus celebrates marathon
Thermopylae here's a picture a modern
picture of Thermopylae this would have
all been water and swamp and the pass is
somewhere like through here with the
mountains that Xerxes with the trader
Ephialtes went around behind it so
marathon Thermopylae Salamis here's the
island here's the bay where the fight
took place and aloose is up here and
Plataea here's the where we think the
Battle of Plataea was fought although
topographers have a lot of trouble they
fight about it a lot but probably
somewhere like this is where the final
battle in 479 happened but these four
battles of them I'll say only that the
Greeks won for us more than perhaps we
will ever understand and this is a
modern rendition of the Battle of
Plataea perhaps the Greeks overstated
the changes that the Persian Menace
would have made but it is certainly true
that the astonishing Greek victory of
479 gave us the invention of history by
Herodotus here's my guy Herodotus states
in his preface that he wrote the Apothic
sis of his history a the display of his
investigation because he felt he had to
sit down the Aragon Megillah to Keiko
Mazda the great and astonishing deeds of
the Greek and barbarian Wars
that's the end of the political section
so on to gender the second topic
involves both sex and gender but I'm
going to deal with gender first because
what I want to say about sex only makes
sense in the larger context of gender
roles for many of us old line feminists
teaching classics the fate of the Furies
at the end of Aeschylus as humanities
seems to sum up pretty neatly the
infuriating role assigned to women in
the public life of Athens they were
honored to be sure but they were also
placed firmly underground out of sight
down under the Parthenon that's why I
chose a kind of idealized painting of
the Acropolis the Parthenon by Frederic
Church whose home about 20 minutes north
of where I teach at Bard you should all
visit if you're ever up in the Hudson
Valley he was a wonderful
nineteenth-century American painter and
the founder of the Hudson Valley school
in the play the Furies now magically
turned into benevolent humanities or
well-disposed ones are entrusted with
the task of keeping the citizen body
obedient to the laws but invisibly as
Pericles famously put it in the funeral
oration in the brief advice he gives to
grieving mothers wives and daughters
quote your great glory is not to be
inferior to what God has made you and
the greatest glory of a woman is to be
least talked about by men whether in
praise or criticism well that's pretty
bad but he had a point and the point I
think was that women were traditionally
in charge of mourning of public mourning
here's luta for us or a mourning vessel
and it shows the women tearing their
hair and doing the traditional morning
although Loog a that accompanied a
especially a well-known person's death
and it could I think Pericles felt
demoralized the city to have too much of
that
here's another Lecco thoughts and this
time it shows the wife stretching out
her hand to the departing husband
probably because the vase was put in her
husband's grave
not a single named Athenian citizen
woman appears in lucidity 'z text and
yet there's a lot more to say about
Greek women in fact I urge you all if
you have the possibility to take
professor Foley's wonderful class that's
offered here it's really terrific I've
learned a lot from her we can find some
entry to the private reality of Greek
lives through myth when press f Annie
was abducted by her uncle Hades we have
a modern picture of this to her mother
the goddess Demeter was not able to
bring her back full time but she was
able to bring both Zeus and Hades to the
table by her threat to let the whole
world starve by refusing to let anything
grow and here's a 17th century picture
of Demeter as the goddess of grain in
the sanctuary of the mother in the
maiden at a lusus and obviously the
stuff on the top is all modern
ceremonies were celebrated every year
for many centuries mysteries that even
the most persistent questioning by the
early church fathers were unable to
bring to light people refused to say
what happened in them the celebration of
these mysteries guaranteed the growing
of grain and also promised a form of
joyous immortality to the initiative the
famous slab of the mother and daughter
giving grain to Tripta Lamas on a human
level Penelope in the Odyssey shows the
kind of sturdy faithfulness and canny
intelligence that kept a home for
Odysseus to return to and I couldn't
resist having a few pictures of Odysseus
struggles here - so here's Odysseus
listening to the sirens but he's bound
so he doesn't have to plunge into the
ocean and destroy himself here they are
taking out Polyphemus as i-i-i probably
shouldn't have put this picture up but i
thought it was so great you can see in
this italian 16th century picture you
can see let me just get the whole thing
the
maddened cows the cattle of the Sun and
the maddened men of Odysseus who are
going to ignore him and eat them and
come to their own destruction
meanwhile back at home Penelope is
unweaving the shroud that she has
promised she had to weave for her
father-in-law and here's a wonderful
19th century painting and weaving on
silk by Dora wheeler of the same thing
the bond that United Greek husbands and
wives was certainly not romantic love
Herodotus inadvertently reveals that
when he comments at almost the beginning
of the histories that King Kundali
solidity Lydia was a man actually in
love with his own wife here's cam
Dolly's and his queen and you can see
guy Gees off in the corner there guy
jeez whom the Queen will give a choice
to I love this scene she calls guy geez
in the next morning and she says guy
cheese you got a choice I only get to be
seen naked by one man it's either you or
him great enough of the women throughout
the histories work to guarantee the
health and survival of their men folk
and children that we can say that
Herodotus presents women as full
partners in the basic social unit of the
polis the family his histories are full
of women protecting their family members
although sometimes in unconventional and
tricky ways it's striking that Herodotus
almost always shows powerful men failing
because they are like kin Dolly's in the
grip of fantasies of their own control
over events where slaves underlings and
women are on the whole much more
successful because they take the trouble
to look closely at reality and the
nature of the immediate situation
confronting them in attic tragedy women
are sometimes toxic or malevolent beings
and of course here I only have to name
the Medea here's one of her early
entrepreneurial efforts and I think she
tricks the two daughters into thinking
that they can boil their father and get
him to live longer and of course it
doesn't work here she is
a fourth century vase killing her kids
and here's a later picture of the same
thing this is dellacroix from 1838 in
Herodotus women generally worked to
support the social order not to subvert
it it's hard to make a case for Medea
but a case can be made for Herodotus as
crafty queens like cam Dolly's wife
Xerxes female general Artemisia or a
mistress wife of Xerxes they exert their
effective powers according to the powers
given to the Furies in humanities to
keep the social structure intact to
protect their families themselves and
the social position that unjust males
are trying to deprive them of the lives
of Greek women were not easy married at
about 13 and here's a famous vase
showing the marriage of Peleus and
Thetis the parents of Achilles from the
6th century married at 13 often to a man
over twice their age they were
responsible for producing the clothing
the foodstuff and an orderly household
for their families I just have some
pictures of Greek women's lives from
pots
here's another 6th century bridal scene
and here's the poor bride being taken on
a couple of mules to her mother-in-law's
house and if you look at the face of the
mother-in-law you can see that her life
is not going to be easy here is a vase
of some women weaving and the standing
loom was called a hysto which was the
same word used for the mast of a ship
something that stood upright here they
are doing the family weaving there are a
lot of vases that have women carrying
water obviously if you have to go to a
well and get all the water from a family
it's a tremendous amount of labour and
here's another well seen and then we
have some scenes that I hope showed that
they had some fun as well here's a scene
of them preparing cows for celebrations
here's women probably in a religious
ceremony doing something like
line dancing and here's a much later 5th
century version of the same thing women
suffered all the ills that Medea
complains of in Europe at ease play
especially those of high mortality for
both mother and child and childbirth
Aristophanes gives voice to other kinds
of complaints in the Lysistrata and I
have here a kind of naughty picture by
Aubrey Beardsley from the 19th century
too many times as we sat in the house
we'd hear that you'd done it again
manhandled another affair of state with
your usual staggering incompetence then
masking our worry with a nervous laugh
we'd ask you brightly how was the
assembly today dear anything in the
minutes about peace and my husband would
give his stock reply
what's that to you shut up and I did and
yet we know from Professor Joan
Connolly's work that names statues of
more than 150 priestesses have been
found women who had as much renown as
the famous politicians of their day
Lysistrata zone name is an allusion to
the real priestess of Athena paulius
Lissa McKee and that may well be true of
other named women in the play as well
the fact that we don't have the writings
of a single woman from the Classical
period and only one Sappho of Lesbos
from archaic Greece says simply that
Pericles was right citizen women
systematically avoided notoriety in the
public sphere of the polis that formed
the evidence we have about Greek lives
some of Sethos poems are available today
largely because male citizens sang her
songs at their symposia and so kept them
alive eventually to be written down and
included in the corpus of Greek lyric
poetry and here we have an early picture
of Sappho and her pal Elsie us both of
them lesbians from the island of lesbos
and here's Alma Thomas 19th century
romantic version of Sappho and Elsie is
having fun singing their songs to each
other now we come to sex like Socrates
we know that we know comparatively
little at least about real Greek citizen
women and their sex lives what we do
know is that citizen males had a
variegated and complex sexual
life amply and even comically
Illustrated on the drinking cups that
provide us much entertaining information
some of which we don't know what to do
with the Greeks were principally still a
rural people and sex was celebrated an
image in a variety of remarkable forms
that make us recall their familiarity
with barnyard life and I'm going to show
you some of the vessels used probably at
their drinking parties and I'll do it
pretty rapidly and without very much
comment if you're offended by vulgarity
you might want a text message somebody
right now or use your cell phones during
this brief part of my presentation the
ancient Greeks were not a prudish people
and they clearly saw a comical side to
sex here's a drinking party where it
would all start and this would be a
slave woman and a Greek man thinking
great thoughts on his couch here's a
seder amusing himself here's a seder
trying to amuse himself with a woman and
there are lots of pots that show satyrs
in a state of avid anticipation there's
another one here is something that
Professor Foley might be able to tell
you about it involves a picture probably
of a slave woman with a basket full of
ceremonial phalluses and a phallus bird
in her hand and this phallus bird seems
to have been part of the ceremony the
secret ceremony for initiates at
Demeter's Eleusinian mysteries but we
don't know much about it it might be
part of what was revealed at the end to
the initiate sets least I don't know the
answer here's a woman riding a phallus
bird and here's a woman carrying her own
very large penis around and I don't know
what what this is about
here is a symposium that has gotten out
of hand and here's another one now these
you know this is in some ways this is
the equivalent of a Playboy magazine or
even penthouse or something yet we're
not I'm not guaranteeing that every
Greek family had these pots in their
house and this is the final one a slave
girl who is one of the drummer's at one
of the symposia
the dark side of all this merriment and
indeed a very dark side to very many
ancient cultures is that the entire
Greek economy was based on the
institution of slavery slaves both Greek
and foreign provided most of the muscle
behind the drawing of water the heavy
lifting of Industry the labor intensive
life of the rural farmer who often
worked beside his slaver to where his
wife worked in the home if they were
lucky with a female slave or two as well
they made clothing provided food and
kept the economa or law of the
household going that's where we get the
word economy from as you all know
certainly all of the heterosexual
activity depicted on the drinking cups
would have taken place between citizen
males and slave women either ones owned
or hired as entertainers for the
occasion of a drinking party as students
of ancient and modern slavery have
taught us sexuality takes on a very
different set of values and meanings in
a culture where one can own other
people's bodies since these bodies can
by definition be treated in any way the
owner wants Diadema the priestess does
not actually come to Plato's symposium
her words are channeled by Socrates the
wife was sequestered in the women's
quarters of her home in a most basic
sense running the family business unless
like the coal key and Medea she had some
very unusual gifts and ideas part of the
terror of Medea is that she is a woman
with a woman's practical intelligence
who also has the honor based values and
sense of her own vast dignity that was
only appropriate to the citizen male the
Lysistrata shows us that sexual tension
between husbands and wives was alive and
well in 5th century Athens
and no doubt a bedrock of family life
but what marriage seems not to have
supplied at least a classical Athenian
culture was romance Plato's symposium
provides a poignant illustration of this
romance erotic love between males is
celebrated by all the speakers although
Aristophanes famous human ball at least
admits the possibility of female female
and female male unions as well as the
more respectable male male ones on to
courtship pots we see the romantic bond
between Arras taste and aroma knows the
male lover in his late 20s and the
younger object of his passion the
pubescent boy that was actively
celebrated in 5th century Athens here's
some a Rasta or older men giving love
gifts to their younger partners and for
some reason the and it doesn't have
the implications that our language would
suggest but the rooster or the bunny
rabbit seemed to be things that you
often gave to your boyfriend or your
would-be boyfriend
here's another vase like that given the
sequestration of women and the disparity
in age between a man's mother and his
father
this arrangement made a lot of sense
romantic passion flourishes between
people who connect and identify with
each other part of its power as Plato
saw is that it enhances the self-respect
of both parties but it also requires as
Plato also saw the touch of Aphrodite
and her needy son eros in Athens the man
who in his 30s married the cloistered
teenage girl his family approved of was
unlikely to have an erotic romantic
passion for her indeed that would have
been thought strange and very improper
the relation of the man in his 20s or
early 30s to the younger man just
learning the ropes in his clans fighting
unit fulfilled a basic human need for
romance especially since the boy's
father would have already been perhaps
50 given the relatively late age at
which men married the older friend could
attend the young man as he moved into
his adult place in the city in the
military unit the palaestra
the assembly the Agora the
drinking party the symposium and this is
a very unusual this is from the tomb of
the diver of a real symposium it's one
of our few wall paintings we possess and
one of my favorite pots I don't know why
but here's a man after the drinking
party who is throwing up and you can see
his highly sympathetic young slave who's
holding his accoutrements while he's
doing so the educational aspects of this
love are sown in Alcibiades puzzled
indeed resentful attraction to Socrates
in Plato's symposium and here's an 18th
century picture of Socrates rescuing
Alcibiades from his favorite occupations
so onto the third and final aspect of
this presentation ancient Greek religion
again the theme of mingled strangeness
and familiarity hits us this time very
hard most of us grew up with some
stories about the Greek gods in myth
without my naming them you could
probably identify Zeus Apollo Athena
here she is popping out of Zeus's head
in her birth and then my favorite
picture of Athena here she is in the
temple of the heck of Tompa dawn all
grown up
Aphrodite Dionysus with his satyrs
attending him with his wine cup the
phonic powers Hades and Persephone if
you look at press F on EES face I think
you can see she's kind of grumpy to be
down there with him the witch hecka T in
her three formed body and this is a
drawing by William Blake
the Furies here's a pot that shows the
Furies asleep and Clytemnestra trying to
wake them up as arrestees is being
purified with the blood of a pig and
Hermes the shapeshifter who goes between
realms he was the god of Thieves
Wayfarers and he also came to take you
to the underworld when you
died in the texts you've read for this
course there's a rough progression from
the eighth century works in which Athena
walks and talks with Odysseus and
Aphrodite fights with Diomedes in the
Iliad down to the early 4th centuries
works of lucidity Xin Plato where the
gods of mythic story either don't appear
at all or are used in quasi allegorical
ways but to think that this means the
real gods of Greek religion became less
relevant or powerful from 750 to 380 BCE
would be a big mistake
poets throughout the ancient Greek world
right down to the coming of Christianity
and be gone beyond could depict gods
anyway they chose Herodotus etymologies
his thigh the Greek word for gods from
faith the a or a stem of the verb
Tiffany to put or to place since the
gods are by definition the beings that
control the order of things and set them
in order here's a second picture of
Athena in the Parthenon and a modern
reconstruction they didn't just have
power the gods were power Athena was the
power that got Odysseus home in the
Odyssey and that informed Athenian
democratic politics in the Oresteia
Demeter was the power that grew the corn
and Zeus was the both of lightning and
all-seeing radiance of the overarching
sky what mattered throughout the ancient
Greek experience was cult sacrifice by
the city the clan the family and the
individual and I've got several Greek
pots showing various cults I'll just go
through rapidly here's maybe a father
and son pouring the oblations and
roasting the meat here's a pig being
slaughtered at a altar ceremonial altar
here's a sacrifice to Hermes and the
herm there you can see has both face and
phallus and this is what was cut off
much to the Athenians distress from all
the worms that were outside their homes
just before the battle
but before the sailing of the Greek
fleet off the Athenian fleet off to
Sicily in Thucydides so that's a
sacrifice to Hermes here's a sacrifice
to Dionysus with a lot of vines hanging
around you can see their ladling out
their vines here but sacrificing here
here's some dancing to Dionysus in
ritual and here's ACORN ceremony where a
young girl brings somehow a basket of
corn on her head to celebrate here's a
final one oddly enough perhaps the Medea
of Euripides vest communicates one basic
religious belief that remains largely
foreign to us in the play jason has
forgotten that madea's grandfather this
is when the couple is a happy couple but
you can see there's already problems
Jason has forgotten that madea's
grandfather is Helios the Sun God and
that Medea herself has real semi divine
powers he cavalierly announces that he
doesn't know Medea anything since
Aphrodite ie the power of sexual
attraction was what made Medea fall in
love with him in the first place
the pitiless nests that Medea shows to
her children is horrifying to us and no
doubt to Europe ADIZ audience but her
witchy ruthlessness also acknowledges
something of a basic Greek understanding
of divinity divine beings had power and
they used it to enforce right behavior
on human beings willy-nilly they
demanded due respect in cult especially
at their own temples and they did
ruthlessly punish human beings who
forgot to honor their power and
propitiate them proper sacrifice ensured
the continued health of an ancient Greek
individual family and city its absence
spelled death or worse the Greek gods
were closely connected to place in
particular locations were infused with
their power
the tragic dramas that we loved were
performed as religious celebrations and
throughout Greece at cult centers
athletic dance drama and music contests
were performed in honor of the gods at
Olympia here's the Temple of Zeus at
Olympia
at Athens here's a scene from below
looking up at the Acropolis and here's
the Parthenon and here's the theater of
Dionysus where most of the tragedies we
have today were performed first also at
the most famous at the healing sanctuary
of Asclepius in Epidaurus and I actually
have stood down on this platform and
whispered the words of the first chorus
of the Bach I and the people who were
with me could hear them up at the top
row of the theater it's a remarkable
acoustic accomplishment the most famous
sanctuary in central Greece was the home
of the Oracle of Apollo at Delphi this
is an omphalos a navel the the Delphian
believed that they lived at the navel of
the earth and this is the actually the
treasury of the Athenians where they
stored the booty that they dedicated to
the God after the Persian Wars
here's more Temple of Apollo there will
be no grand wrap-up conclusion to this
talk I want to end instead with a little
meditation on the power that Apollo
exerts from Delphi in what Aristotle
called the most perfect tragedy of all
the Oedipus Chirinos Oedipus was allowed
by the Sphinx into Thebes because he
could answer the riddle of the ages of
man and he could answer the riddle
because he himself represented
simultaneously all of those ages he was
the limping four-legged white a puss the
wounded foot child of Jocasta he was
also her two-legged husband by the end
of the day the end of the tragedy he
will be the three-legged blind old man
led from the stage he will be broken by
the God but he will also in a sense have
become Taurus
he will know who he is in Sophocles much
later play the Oedipus at Colonus
written at the end of the Peloponnesian
War
Oedipus becomes semi-divine himself
because of his sufferings he becomes a
hero who can protect Athens in her time
of greatest calamity
Sophocles is not representative of a
normal Greek religious Sensibility I
think he was himself a mystic a sort of
religious genius and was heroines by the
Athenians after death why did he make
Oedipus the doubly polluted murderer of
his father and sexual partner of his
mother a hero at the end one answer is
that Oedipus experiences the loss of
everything he loves and thinks he knows
including his own brilliant abilities as
a self-made man a torah knows yet he
persists in finding out the nature of
the curse that has been destroying his
adopted city and in finding out that he
is himself the curse he also discovers
that he has not after all been a
self-made man he is rather the true king
and legitimate heir to the throne of
Thebes in finding this out and
acknowledging it Oedipus becomes not
just the cause of pollution for Thebes
but also its savior acting as the gods
agent in driving out the pollution that
is himself as Oedipus himself says in
the play Apollo the civilizing God of
song and prophesy is the real dramaturg
of the action for Apollo acting through
the Oracle at Delphi predicted that lie
is's son would destroy him sent the
young Oedipus fleeing corinth sent the
sphinx that led liest to the place where
three roads meet and finally sent the
plague that put Oedipus on his quest in
pushing Oedipus toward self-knowledge
Apollo blasts but he also heals and
ultimately transforms him I hope you can
all get to Delphi someday where the rock
rises starkly behind the shrines to
Parnassus and the olive groves to the
South glint in the sunlight as the earth
slopes down to the Gulf of Corinth it is
a magical place ultimately
the Greek gods are tied to the beauty of
the land itself and in a way that evades
description the savage beauty of the
Delphian landscape hangs over and
encompasses the very different beauty of
Sophocles Oedipus tyrannous a play about
a man broken but ultimately remade in
wisdom and self-knowledge by the gods so
we end here where we began at Delphi
where the priestess was the God's
mouthpiece for a thousand years until it
was closed by the Christian Emperor
Theodosius in 395 of the Common Era but
there's one more image a metaphor I want
to end with that concerns a hero who
played a minor part in your course and
Gnaeus the son of Aphrodite whom
Poseidon saves from Diomedes in book 20
of the Iliad we know Aeneas best from a
work you will read next semester the
Aeneid where we learned that he fled
burning troy carrying his old father and
Kies ease on his back in valuing these
old texts you 21st century citizens of
the world are also in a way Aeneas even
though most of you like me probably have
not a speck of biological Greek DNA we
carry this ancient Western cultural
heritage in all its ambiguities on our
backs with us if we are lucky like
Anchises whom Aeneas meets again in the
underworld these texts will stay with
you and become living parts of your
imagination something that you can
continue to use long after my generation
has taught it off to the old folks home
they are texts good to think with in
shaping your sense of your own lives in
the difficult world you will inhabit
Thanks
I hope you'll agree with me that there
was so much to learn both about the
Greeks and I suppose about life more
generally in those wonderful images
unless like myself you took your glasses
off during some of the images professor
- world was kind enough to say that she
would be happy to take questions so does
anyone have a question you'd like to
pose
please come along
this is a question that my literature
humanities teacher has often berated me
for asking because he says that it
doesn't really make sense a sense in the
context of the way the Greeks live their
lives but it seems that in terms of
genealogy of the gods there isn't a lot
of equality our kilee is who's the son
of a nymph is able to kill a son of Zeus
it doesn't seem like the Greeks thought
of genealogy in terms of dilutions of
power
how would do you think that descendants
of gods played out in terms of Greek
culture that's a really good question
and it's a hard one to answer and this
is just my off the top of the head I'm
not a scholar of Greek religion in fact
for the very first time although I'd
been teaching for 35 years last year I
finally decided to teach Greek religion
and I said Greek religion is sort of as
though Martians 400 years from now or
4000 years from now we're trying to
reconstruct baseball on the on with only
the evidence of baseball cards
to confront them so I'm not sure what
I'm saying is right but I think the
Greeks were very practical people and if
you had someone who had extraordinary
abilities the kind of abilities that
save for us a math genius you know the
kind of kid who mystically at age seven
knows things that college professors
don't know about math or Mozart this
kind of ability they would say by
definition the God would have been the
father of that child Apollo probably in
the case of music so there was there was
a sense that the person who was an
extraordinary warrior must have a divine
and a seed n'd him achilles is
particularly interesting because we also
have the alternate myth that what Zeus
learned just in time not to rape Thetis
was that if Zeus had impregnated the
she would have given birth to the son
who would unseat him and that's why
fetus was given off to a mortal so that
Achilles would simply be a superlatively
moral mortal hero not a divine one I
don't know if that answers your question
but it is an interesting question
there's also the funny story from
Herodotus I don't know if you read it
about the king of Sparta who stole his
best friend's wife and eight months
later she gave birth to a son and there
was some doubt about the paternity of
the boy when he grew up his political
enemies tried to prosecute and he goes
to his mother and put sacrificial
offerings in her hand and says come on
mom tell me the truth and she tells him
a version about the hero of the family
coming looking just like her husband and
impregnating her and so she he was the
son of both the divine patron of the
house and his father well the King
involved democrates he shrugs packs and
takes off for Persia so he clearly
doesn't believe his mother's version I
don't know that's the best I can do
thank you sure I was just wondering I
mean as a scholar of Herodotus what your
thoughts were on how even though you
know the paradox that even though he's
viewed as the father of Western history
his historiographical
and even derided by I mean Thucydides in
particular and he's just not it's you
know people don't write history the way
he does I'm just yeah that's it's really
exciting my generation had had the great
good luck to be involved in really what
we now call the postmodern and
post-structuralist
era and Herodotus we've we've read we
read now completely differently from the
way we read Herodotus in say 1960
completely differently and I think those
of us who take her out at us seriously
we see him as as much an anthropologist
and so
geologist as a historian what he was
doing was taking a culture that was
completely oral what am I gonna do in
order to give you context he would think
so that you could understand the Persian
Wars he was in East Greek my theory is
that he got to central Greece he got to
Athens and Sparta and Corinth and Thebes
and realized that the Greeks of the
mainland didn't know squat about the
eight the Eastern countries that he had
grown up with and so he started giving
lectures but as he gave lectures he also
encoded you know in this story of how
the Persian Empire grew and then how it
first confronted Greeks and then the two
great periods of collision between
Greeks and Persians what he did was take
stories and encode them in his narrative
pretty much as he heard them because
that's all he had there that was all
there was was oral history and he knows
that a lot of it is likely not to be
true I think that's why he starts with
that funny set of abductions at the
beginning because as you recall or maybe
one of you can answer who is it that
tells those stories of the abductions do
you remember who is it that Herodotus
hears them from Persians exactly so what
he's telling you is every story is
you're gonna have to take every one of
my anecdotes and think about who told it
because it's always going to have to be
framed by the self-interest of the
teller he's profoundly ironic about his
sources and about his stories but it's
the best he can do so I actually think
at this point that he has a kind of
genius that lucidity 'he's the brilliant
professional historian builds on but
wouldn't necessarily have had himself
but what Thucydides is trying to do is
say look you know I am a general I'm
somebody who understands this war
because I was in it and the Athenians
lost we lost we lost our empire we lost
our Navy and Army and I'm gonna tell you
exactly why so lucid --'tis aim is
different it's the bitter a
of someone who is saying this is what
you have to do to make your country live
we I'm tempted to use vulgar language
here but we gave away our power by
making stupid decisions and I'm going to
tell you exactly what those were sorry
this is a dangerous area to get into I
could spend another three hours here so
I'll stop thank you very much for coming
I really enjoyed this so so if I can
just say I really want to thank
professor Dewalt so much for coming down
today and so enlightening us in so many
ways I also don't want to thank you for
turning up today and thank you for all
your attendance through the semester at
the various events we've had I hope
you've had a wonderful first semester
Inlet um thank you